[Musique]
c'est je suis danny rand
j'ai été absent pas mal de temps viens
tu as rien à faire ici
je suis d'ailleurs end attendez les gars
bienvenue chez rennes entreprises
j'ai quitté cette ville quand j'avais 10
ans dans un avion avec mes parents
j'étais le seul survivant
dany rennes revenu d'entre les morts
pourquoi at il attendu aussi longtemps
pour se montrer comment at il appris les
arts martiaux s'étaient entraînés ou
kunlun
mon père m'a toujours élevés dans
l'amour et dans le respect de cette
entreprise ici c'est chez moi c'est mon
entreprise
la ville de new york des bases un
endroit pour danic est arrivé exactement
et pourquoi tu es revenu les sites de
mauvaise personne ont infiltré notre
entreprise c'est criminel
je sais ce qu'ils sont et de quoi ils
sont capables d'avaler des capacités
hors normes
[Musique]
j'ai été entraîné très dur toute ma vie
pour ce moment c'est ma destinée
j.gerard
je viens avec toi donc tu restes tu as
besoin de moi
il va bientôt y avoir du changement tu
pourras réaliser tout son potentiel
je suis le iron fist qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
[Musique]